contouring to do this
holy shit where the hell am i I mean my
new set the conjuring 2 is directed by
James Wan and stars Vera Farmiga Patrick
Wilson and a lot of very scared children
the first conjuring I thought was very
good I thought it was one of the better
horror films I had seen in a long time
in James Wan I think is probably the
best director working in horror today so
I was really excited to see this movie
this film once again is about the
warrants investigating a case of a
haunting in a house in England this
little girl is experiencing strange
things at night voices all kinds of
craziness and it gets intense as you
might expect despite the fact that you
might expect a lot of the things that
happen in this movie and it does follow
virtually every conventional horror
thing that you would expect
it's the craft and the performances and
the writing that really launched this
ahead of all films of its kind out right
now the conjuring 2 is really good I had
a ton of fun with this movie this is a
damn good horror film it is scary is
suspenseful the tension is real I felt
it palpable throughout the entire film
and a lot of that is due to excellent
cinematography and sound design and like
I said really good performances
especially from the young girl who is
most tormented in this film by this
entity as well as beer Farmiga and
Patrick Wilson who played that married
couple who really grounded the film in
realism for me because obviously there's
some crazy shit going on in this movie
but their performances as a couple and
their story and the arc for them was so
sweet and really really touching and
heartfelt the film is not just about
scary horror things it's also about
marriage and being with somebody that
understands you and the film grounds
itself in that type of realistic
families story it's their performances
and their story as well as the families
tight-knit community that they're trying
to maintain with each other they all
protect each other they try to be a good
family to one another that really makes
this film better than your average
horror film and not just because of the
craft and because of the fact that it
actually is scary
but it's that emotional story that keeps
it grounded it keeps it weighted in
something that you can relate to and
that gives it an arc that gives it
something to care about it's not just
about jump scares are there jump scares
yes there are but they're not false
James Wan once again proves how to use a
jump scare everything that startles you
in this movie is meant to startle you
some creepy shit happens and it's meant
to get you it's meant to make you jump
James Wan understands how to build
tension how to mount tension until it
feels insurmountable and not just
because the sound goes out of the movie
for a second and you're expecting a loud
noise but because of expert art
direction and the fact that you actually
do care about these characters and so
when some of the really creepy shit
starts happening you feel for these
characters and thusly you feel kind of
terrified for them and that's one of the
reasons conjuring 2 is so good it's also
just very entertaining it's a really
entertaining horror film it's fast paced
the scenes that do build character don't
feel like they drag when compared to the
nighttime scenes where there's creepy
shit going on those scenes are always
the ones you are excited about in a
horror film but in this film I was
actually excited about the smaller
character moments too because the
characters were so well rounded and
that's one of the things that's so great
about this movie it presents real people
in the middle of this crazy situation
and so you care you feel like yes like I
feel bad for these people I wish this
wasn't happening to them I actually
found myself enjoying this one more than
the first one which I really liked this
is a damn good horror film far better
than any of the other horror films I've
seen recently and I can strongly
strongly recommend it yes it does fall
back on every traditional horror cliche
that you might expect there's people
with the sound devices and video camera
equipment and the sounds and the noises
and tape recorders and you get it you
know you've seen it all before but like
I said it's the craft and the writing
and the performances that really elevate
the material I'm going to give the
conjuring to an A
it is definitely worth seeing guys and I
hope you like my new background I am
working on it still I can't guarantee
that every video over the next few
months is going to be here because we're
not officially moved in yet but I'll try
to do a lot of videos here because it's
a much bigger space
I love the background I love filming
here so bear with me as I learned how to
film here and I tweaked things about the
background it's going to be a lot of fun
to film here and guys definitely see
this movie the film was great the
experience of seeing it though slightly
different story do you guys remember a
few years ago I did a video called a
rant on Annoying moviegoers I'm thinking
there's a part two coming to that yep
it's got to happen it's got to happen
guys I need the therapy I need it I need
to make a video about the experience I
just had tonight and I'm going to
that'll be very soon thank you guys so
much as always for watching and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes